david there's a lot of discussion about
income inequality
if we accept that it's a problem
how can we actually fix it okay this is
a good question
um let's not debate whether income
inequality is a problem
let's accept that it is and that's not
what this segment is about
we can talk about whether it's a problem
in another segment i believe that it is
and i've outlined why
many times the most important
fact to realize about fixing income
inequality
is that we don't need to come up with
anything new
we we have essentially all the ideas we
need
to deal with income inequality now to be
very clear
i don't believe that we need perfect
distribution of income
perfect distribution equality of
outcomes so to speak
is not naturally occurring anywhere i
don't believe it would be good to force
it
i'm not a socialist i don't believe
there would be any reasonable
reasonable expectation that everybody
has the same amount of money what i do
think as a social democrat though
is the bottom should be lifted there
should be a safety net
that says we're not going to allow
people to fall below this level
and then at the top you should have more
restrictions about okay
if we say billionaires are okay are
multi-billionaires turbo billionaires
what at what point do we want to be
saying now is when you've got to really
be redistributing it's a gray area
different people would put it at a
different
different spot we have all of the
different
tools but the problem is getting the
right combination so as an example
should the minimum wage be higher than
it is right now
of course is a 15 minimum wage
nationally going to solve the problem of
inequality
no we need a higher minimum wage exactly
what it should be probably depends on
the state that we're in
but a 15 minimum wage isn't even a
living wage in many states based on cost
of living so
do we need to raise the minimum wage yes
there will be people who come in and say
well
if a higher minimum wage is better why
not just make it 200
an hour that's not an equilibrium wage
anywhere
and that's a red herring don't fall for
it do we need a more robust social
service system
funded by taxes on the very very rich
but that includes financial transactions
and some of these other ideas yeah we've
got the tools we know what it would look
like
there's just no political will to do it
right now
do we need better educational access
regardless of income because one of the
great equalizers is
education and unfortunately in our
society
yes there are scholarships yes we know
about all that stuff
but the reality is um there is very low
income mobility in the united states and
part of that is because there is not
widespread
good education that is accessible to
people who start off in an economically
disadvantaged position
trade is part of it you know trump talks
about trade and some trade things can be
bad for the middle class
i'll concede that you've got to look at
trade we can look at things like
universal basic income or
a value-added tax and there's pros and
cons to all of these
my point is there are no new tools that
are necessary to deal with income
inequality
but we have to get away from do nothing
and let the markets handle it
because we know that doesn't work we
know that doesn't work
i'm fine as a social democrat letting
markets work to direct resources
in many industries as i've said before i
don't need the government
making all the cell phones or making all
the airplanes but
i sure as hell want the government
involved in regulating those industries
and well-regulated markets where private
industry is manufacturing stuff
i'm fine with certain areas need to be
taken out of that healthcare
education you could argue that some
basic level of
housing should be taken out of that it's
a debate in the gray area but we've got
all the tools
we need to figure out how to put them
together in the right proportions
send in your questions for next week's
audience questions through
our website davidpakman.com we have a
great bonus show for you today and
remember that on august 23rd
the 15th anniversary of the david pakman
show
we will be doing a one day huge
membership special it will be based on
the theme of 15 years
and you can be notified of it by jumping
on our free newsletter
at davidpakman.com